crazy technology will work all right
hello everybody
we are here with a little different
episode
from our normal our normal fair on the
into the impossible
podcast i don't know why my rabbinical
guest is not showing up let me try this
one more time
uh maybe i need to add
how do i do this this is the real thing
i should figure out before i start
let's see here let me go to a different
screen
here uh and the eye there's a way to do
this
i believe it's in skype let me go to
skype over here
let me go to settings on skype
audio and video we got some crying
babies in the background but that's okay
it's all freewheeling here uh
let's see i'm trying to get you up on
the screen rabbi that's just taking me
one second
to remind myself how to do this yeah
exactly where are we gonna go it's a
pandemic
we're not gonna go anywhere uh let's see
ndi skype guest ndi
let me do that let's see now i don't see
anybody
uh include skype guest
ndi yeah that's weird happy hanukkah
everybody give me one second
and try and figure this out on the fly
ecamm is not letting me do this but i've
solved it before ah
how do i do that remote guest via skype
this all be edited out rob rabbi don't
worry this will be
edited out in post-production open skype
open skype preferences in the calling
section
that's what i forgot calling let's see
only allow calling advanced
allow ndi usage there we go if this
doesn't do it nothing will and there you
are
beautiful rabbi hello sir hi there now
we are live and i'm going to add myself
back
in i'm going to remove you i'm going to
switch this around
now we're going to add in the rabbi boom
there we go hello everybody welcome to
the special
hanukkah miracle of lights and miracle
of technology
with uh america's rabbi this is uh
rabbi david walpy thank you uh so much
for joining us on the into the
impossible podcast is their second
appearance on our show
indeed becoming a regular yeah what do
they call the hazaka or whatever when
it's three times
we'll do that we'll do pesach we'll do a
pesach
uh serenade or a purim serenade
hopefully we can get it all done
um so tonight i wanted to do an honor of
this being the first night of hanukkah i
wanted to
kind of get some of my questions
answered but also to answer some
questions of the viewers
including some of these very erudite
people that i get to speak to on the
into the impossible podcast
and you should know that you were
actually
um you're being sandwiched you're you're
part of a sandwich
between two nobel prize winners so you
know i figure if if you know
they have to live up to your reputation
you're exactly sure
so i had on multiple nobel prize winners
and uh this week and and tomorrow and uh
it's just such a treat that i get to
have you here and i thought we would
begin
with first of all dispelling some myths
about hanukkah
the first one that i get from nobel
caliber intellects is that
hanukkah is jewish christmas and then it
came about
uh you know it's basically a response to
christmas so that little jewish boys and
girls like me
would be happy with a pair of slacks or
you know something when they're when
their friends from other religions were
getting you know huge matchbox car sets
to dwarf my son but anyway
is it just jewish christmas well that
that
would have would be a better argument if
in fact it didn't predate the birth of
jesus by several hundred years
or at least a few hundred years um in
fact
it was about the struggle it's
post-biblical
but it's in that sort of interregnum in
the time between the close of the bible
and the talmudic or christian era
depending on how you
look at it um and what happened was that
the seleucids the greeks
and the jews battled over the
sovereignty of jerusalem and
also jews battled with themselves
hanukkah is a little bit of a civil war
as well as being a as well as being a
fight for religious liberty
um because uh as always
you know as is always the case uh the
minority culture starts to disappear
into the majority culture
and the maccabees were fighting to
retain the integrity of judaism
in a in a hellenized world so
um the truth is that hanukkah has
absolutely nothing to do
with christmas uh however having said
that
it also has become in america
particularly salient because it
happens at the same time as christmas so
we shouldn't pretend that one thing has
nothing to do with the other in fact
um we know that for people in a
christian culture
because they're both winter holidays
because they both
involve light in the darkness because
they come at the same time it has
it has become
more important in the jewish calendar
than it really is in the jewish calendar
it is a relatively minor holiday but
it's become important because it
happens at the same time as christmas
right so it's natural that
one might expect them to sort of take on
similar sorts of
at least appeal or or notoriety in the
minds of
both adherents and non-adherents and
actually i was under the impression that
you know that it came later than
christmas for some reason but of course
it couldn't really
right because um the actual story is is
very deep and i think it makes
uh it makes for an interesting story at
least in my mind
that i view hanukkah sort of preserving
western civilization or western at least
freedom of religion in some sense and
monotheism
uh because of really the the ancient
greeks
uh you know disdain for the jewish
culture and actually
that the story i always remember hearing
and this is one of the talmudic
disputes that we can discuss but i
remember thinking as a kid okay so let's
say i have a
a gas tank in my car and it only has
enough to get home
and uh you know one mile to drive one
mile and i live eight miles away
right uh and all right so maybe i
miscalculated
wha what is the nature of this miracle
that's publicized by lighting menorahs
why what does the menorah have to do
with it so i would say first of all two
things
um the menorah the original menorah was
in the temple
um but it had uh six
well seven really because of the center
piece um
wix i suppose uh and that's why some
people don't like calling the hanukkah a
menorah because it's not exactly the
same as the menorah
but i just want to say that anybody who
if you say in monarchy they correct you
they're being a little pedantic
okay it's like you can call it a menorah
um
jews be pedantic you don't say that
um if you want to be really correct you
can call it a hanukkah menorah but
if you you don't have to um so it's like
when somebody says i love rabbi wolpi
he's one of my favorite jewish rabbis
i say exactly are there other kinds yeah
right are there other kinds
um so however what i've always found
interesting the story of the the story
of the miracle first of all is a later
story we don't find it in the original
story of the maccabees
um but let us assume that that was in
fact the miracle
what interests me and what goes to your
point is
so it was supposed to last for one night
and it lasted for eight nights
and therefore we light eight nights of a
miracle but the truth is
we should only lie for seven nights
because if it was supposed to last for
one night
then only seven nights were a miracle
not all eight nights
and this is a question that was already
asked by uh in the 1500s i believe by
joseph caro
um and and a lot of answers have been
given but i actually think that the
answer is what you say which is
that the great miracle is that after
the destruction or the near destruction
the trashing of the temple and so on and
so they still wanted to light
that judaism survived it all so in a
sense the first night is the great
miracle and the fact that we still
liked thousands of years later is the
miracle
so i find hanukkah be a very inspiring
holiday because as you say
it is the assertion of a minority
culture
that what we believe which is sacred to
us
should be preserved and can't be overrun
simply because it's not what the
majority believes
and that theme has been
sort of the like motif of jewish history
because we've always been a minority
uh at least most of our history and the
only place we haven't been a minority is
in israel
so uh and even there at times we were a
minority because we
were expelled as a result hanukkah is
deeply thematic um and
important and the menorah too i remember
a story in rabbi
you must know this better than me but of
uh of a sage who
wanted very much to go to rome and he
wanted to go to the arch of titus to see
it
and i remember the story goes something
like this you know he goes to the arch
of titus he's an old man
a very old rabbi and he goes to the arch
of titus and he and he looks at it and
he screams like
i am here and yiddish i am here where
are you rufus
where are you in other words the jewish
culture the the the jews have survived
and
you know i'm not prone to believe in
miracles it doesn't come easy to me as a
scientist
but the existence of of of such a people
uh you know throughout history despite
how many times we've been tried to be
annihilated and
and overwhelmed and overcome and that
we've endured and thanks to the
tradition of
of teachers like you and and others uh
that this has been maintained but but
really the
there is no greek culture i mean they're
greeks and i have many many good friends
that are
but they don't practice the same culture
of the same you know
yeah they don't they don't read ancient
greek as a modern
language whereas any school child can
read the bible
in israel and i want to say something
about that in a second but first
let me just to those of your listeners
who don't know what you mean by the
archetype
that it preserves in stone roman
soldiers carrying the menorah from the
temple
yeah because that was and it was a it
was an act of triumph we destroyed your
temple
and here is our here's the menorah and
of course i have to say
when i when i first saw it i thought the
same thing with that old guy
you just guess what here i am i'm a jew
thousands of years later the roman
empire
has fallen and gone and we're still here
um it reminds me of a wonderful story of
saul bellow the nobel prize winning
writer
jewish american writer who
when he went to israel he tells i think
he tells the story in his book to
jerusalem and back
he meets shai agno who was the uh
who was the first israeli nobilist along
with a poet named nelly sax
in 64. and and i've known says to bellow
who
i mean some people knew i've known but
bello was really world famous and he
wrote english not because he wrote in
english
um so unknown says develop are your are
your novels translated into hebrew
and beloved says yes they are and i've
known says oh thank god you're safe
because as far as our news concerns you
know
english could come and go but he was
going to be here in a thousand years if
you want translated into hebrew
you could be gone
yeah it's really true though the
perseverance of uh
as a people and as a culture and
basically that you could be teleported
back
you know to jerusalem to uh to the
shtetl in europe
and you could get along you know with
with uh the weekly services and the
holiday services
you would know what to say and and and
even bring down some
some interesting factoids that have been
transmitted through our
tradition for thousands of years it's
very remarkable
yeah the continuity of that is really
and and i think all the time when i read
um the hebrew bible and it talks about
you know the hittites
and the jebusites and i think the only
reason anybody knows
people who are much much larger than the
jewish people is because they were
enemies of the jews or because they had
some contact with the jews
right and so that's the only reason we
remember that
it is it is a historical miracle take
that naturalistically or
supernaturalistically however you want
yeah and so you know from the
perspective of
looking at uh you know the culture that
that we
are a part of and the activity of it um
i think
it's sort of a miracle also that when
you look at those stories
um people have to realize that the
hittites you know and with the ammonites
and so forth that are talked about like
i used to gloss over this they said well
i wouldn't need to learn about these
kings and about um but i realized that
it's pretty it's pretty astounding it
would be like we're writing a story
about
you know the jews and and when we're
talking about like people in germany
and how the jews got along with it that
would actually testify to the
to the authenticity of a document when
you put in
that jews that weren't always enemies of
of these different peoples or the
canaanites and whatever
and actually they intermarried and so
forth and the question of
you know how um how accurate is this
document and and sometimes i think that
that's why it's
in the torah to give us not a history
lesson but just
a test to the accuracy and authenticity
of this document
i it's there's no question about the
fact
that um for much of jewish for much of
the story of the torah
jews were assimilating as opposed to
conquering or
at odds with and and and one of the ways
you know that is because the prophets
were always yelling at them about it
they're always saying don't
the upcoming new month is coming uh next
next week uh we enter in and that's of
course when the moon is new
actually we have a very interesting
celestial event
occurring on monday which is a total
eclipse of the sun
uh which is visible from chile i was
supposed to be there i
certainly hope you you're not going to
expect me to speak about that no
i yes that would be like you know you
asking me to speak of
give a davar toronto
but it is rabbi you'll be interested
that's the one time you know for sure
it's rush hours
when there's a total eclipse of the sun
and my theory is and i'm
looking to work with some bright
students someday about this but
my theory is uh that the rabbis were
said to know or the ancient israelites
were saying to know
the length of the month to within a few
seconds
and given the technology 3000 years ago
i find that almost impossible unless
they were able to sort of calibrate it
and they knew and they understood
celestial you know at least astronomical
events well enough
to say that every time there's an
eclipse we have we know two weeks later
there'll be a likelihood for a lunar
eclipse and we could actually time it
because otherwise they didn't have
watches look galileo didn't have a watch
you know newton barely had a watch and
so uh you think about how much science
was conducted and how do they know the
length of and why is it
why is it the lunar calendar that we use
as jews why is that so
why is that instead of the solar
calendar i don't know what the
i mean i it's the bible uses the lunar
calendar i don't
i i mean the excellent and by the way i
think that the babylonians who had
fairly sophisticated astronomical
knowledge also used a lunar calendar um
the i can tell you the spiritual meaning
of using a lunar calendar but how it
happened historically i don't know
uh the spiritual meaning i've always
heard is that as you point out you
declare the new month
when the sky is dark which means that
you believe in the promise of the time
to come that it's going to grow lighter
and lighter and lighter
um but but and but that
and also i will say it led to many
over the course of jewish history there
were many struggles over the exact
calendar because it's very hard to
figure out
um when you have a lunar calendar uh how
to calculate
each year when various events are
that's one of the reasons why for those
of you that's getting a little bit into
the weeds
but for those of you who know that that
outside of the land of israel there are
two days of yomtov two days of the
beginning and end of a holiday
it's because people weren't sure outside
of israel when the new moon was declared
so it took a little while for the to get
there and they wanted to make sure that
they covered the right day
but as i say this the calendrical
calculations i'm going to leave to you
yeah that's that's my
that'll be uh a thesis
that's right if you ever want to pick up
your ged and and astrophysics um i'm
your man
um well i was in israel uh uh 12
13 14 years ago my first time in israel
on hanukkah
and i remember you know coming back and
on the plane ride home
uh they were playing uh of all movies
they were playing my big fat greek
wedding it was like 2003
or something and i remember like i just
come back and i just heard about you
know
how the jews triumphed over the assyrian
greeks and
and how crap you know the the word for
for greece or
syria greece sort of has a connotation
of darkness
and on ll they were playing the movie
and there's a scene where he basically
goes into a mikvah
the the male lead character and he comes
out of the mikvah
and then uh and he says i'm greek and
and i remember like the subtitles say
um it says mazel tov and then it says
which i just learned is like that means
like you're spiritually dark and
you're irredeemably you know in fairness
though
in case you have greeks watching your i
love you fairness the jews took a lot
from greek culture uh not as much as
christianity did
yes christianity really was a balance of
of as
as it used to be said hebrews meant
hellenism um
but judaism too took uh a bit from greek
quite a bit from greek culture
um and greek obviously ancient greek
culture enriched the world
tremendously uh the way that uh the way
that
famously matthew arnold described the
two streams the stream of
judaism and the stream of greek culture
into christianity was that the greeks
believed
in the holiness of beauty and the jews
believed in the beauty of holiness
and of course in america i see you know
kind of this union
uniquely so of greek attitudes towards
you know
culture beauty aesthetics but also
math and science and some of the words
we get in hebrew
it's funny like i always knew from my
israeli friends that the only curse
words in hebrew are from other languages
and and even
the word for like heretic in hebrew is
like apicoros which is like
epicurean which is like yeah which is a
good idea
yeah and uh but i also then i'll point
out gematria which is like geometry
comes from from greek as well so i i
think there are very
interesting similarities and differences
as i might have said to you once before
you know people ask me about well like
the torah and science are they in
conflict and i say well
science in latin you know obviously the
romans derived a lot from the greeks
means knowledge but it doesn't mean
wisdom and torah means more
of a sense of of of of wisdom and the
connotation thereof
and and even the way that we teach it
like a teacher like ptolemy or socrates
very different than a rabbi
a rabbi is sort of like uh and even the
word for teacher
um i believe is similar to the word for
parent in hebrew isn't that correct
rabbi
well moray moran
our teacher and you're supposed to give
the same um
honor to your teacher that you do to a
parent yes
so i think that love of wisdom the love
of learning are common between them and
then of course
we don't want religious uh we don't want
religious you know kind of governance
but uh but otherwise i think you know
america is this beautiful wonderful
they call it the golden medina right the
yeah so yeah i mean
it is also i think it is also true that
cultures tend to
define themselves in opposition to the
people that they were around
so i think there was also a certain
amount of pushback it's one of the
reasons by the way people don't think
about this
why is the jewish sabbath on saturday
the christian sabbath on sunday and the
muslim sabbath on friday
because when christians wanted to
distinguish themselves from jews
they changed the day when muslims wanted
to distinguish themselves from
christians and jews they changed the day
were adopted a different day
everybody and jews have done that in
reaction as well
everybody you know says well i do you
want to know what i am i'm not this
right this that's right that's right we
define both by ourselves and also by
others it's inevitable we're social
creatures
yeah we define ourselves by our
neighbors like canadians feel closer to
mexicans
than to americans and we like guatemala
i don't know that's right um so we got
some questions for you
uh about about is it true that string
theory
is related to sit-c now that's that's i
made that up i made that up
uh we're not going to go there uh susan
murray is wondering what ethnicity is
rabbi will be
jewish so now if you want to know my uh
my ancestry yeah um my name uh
comes almost certainly from a small town
called
wapa outside of outside of uh
warsaw lithuania i am not i mean in uh
i'm sorry
not we're at vilna outside um in
lithuania
and in fact if you go on online you can
see the walpa synagogue which was a
famous wooden synagogue
some of my family went to south africa
some came to the united states some went
to israel
uh and russia poland all eastern
european jewish
um in fact when i took my 23andme
my dna test my daughter was somewhat
disappointed to learn
that i really had a very unexotic
background it was just
almost all it was like 98 or 99
um eastern european jewish though there
was a small percent like point
six percent of some celtic tribe that
had an affinity to the vikings so i'm
holding on to that
interesting i said that once you know to
my
to my dad i took a genetic test and i
was 99
99.7 ashkenazi jew and he said
but you're 100 genetic garbage and then
and then i said well you know
somebody else said like i'm 99 percent
you know sephardic
but one percent ashke and i said well
nobody's perfect yes
somewhere back there somebody yeah
you know somebody yeah
right so but it is true you said
ethnicity you know ethnicity kind of uh
as a joke you're jewish but it is true
it's like we as jews
we i converted to catholicism i was
actually an altar boy
instead of getting a bar mitzvah at age
13 i was an altar boy in the catholic
church because my mother
married an irish catholic man and i
married into their family
and actually have his name i would talk
about irish catholic my last name
keating
isn't hebrew it's irish and it means
actually
kite flyer in norwegian irish so
you and i could have you know really the
old country united
but but um but they say that i never
left judaism how is that how can i not
have left it
i don't don't have to do something to
come back to it
so this is a very interesting and and
this is one of those questions that is
deeply impacted by history
um there was there is a phrase in the
talmud
israel israel which means an israelite
even if he sins remains an israelite
and originally the meaning was look
everybody stands everybody does
bad things you can be jewish or you can
sin you're still jewish it doesn't mean
you don't have to repent but you're
jewish however
during the spanish inquisition when many
jews converted
under penalty of death then
later after the inquisition waned rabbis
wanted to make it easy for jews to
return to judaism
because otherwise they were afraid they
would lose a whole generation
so they use that phrase and israelite
even if he sins remains in israel like
to say
you can't convert out of judaism
even if you convert you remain jewish
and all you really have to do is come
back
so as a result halachically speaking
speaking legally if somebody is born
jewish
or converts to judaism they remain
jewish for the rest of their life
yeah in practical terms sometimes people
have asked for a symbolic
to go to the mikvah um or
honestly organically the the community
has rejected people if they adopt a
different religion and stick with it
so if somebody for example who was born
jewish
and came into my synagogue and was a
practicing christian has to be called up
to the torah
i would say that's not appropriate
that's for jews who identify and are
practicing as jews
but if they said to me but legally am i
not jewish i would have to say yes
legally you are yeah and that's maybe
another way that jews and
i identify via the negation or
distinction of another culture when
you're a christian you're not christian
if you deny that jesus christ is a
savior or something like this
um and so yeah i was going to say this
is a this is a question i get all the
time and i really i want to emphasize
because i get jews and christians for
example who want an intermarriage
and don't understand this distinction
which is that judaism is not a religion
in the sense of christianity as you
correctly point out if tomorrow
i come on your podcast and i say oh you
know all that jewish stuff i believed
yesterday
i was wrong it's all wrong i'm still
equally jewish
because what judaism is is a religious
family
you're born into a family you can enter
a family
but the only way you actually can leave
a family is if you
consciously choose another family and
reject your own
so as i said organically if you choose
another religion
judaism more or less declares you're not
jewish even though legally you are
yeah um that's not true with
christianity because it's not familial
it's belief-based yeah
i was taken in and just as if my
actually my uh great my step
you know grandmother she thought that
the conversion to catholicism
meant like i genetically became like she
started saying like you should get your
doctor to check this gene then i i'm
like what are you talking about
it doesn't quite work that way grandma
uh but uh but
but of course it's you know i i think
you know there there are different
approaches to it and people
you know i used to be more sort of
thinking about well
how can somebody you know convert and
get married you know i have intermarried
couples in my family obviously my mother
married a non-jew or a second marriage
um and i think uh you know at different
times people
as jews someone's asking about the
maternal bloodline why is that the
important
um side of things maybe you'll take that
but then i want to ask
you know your your impression about you
know for a long time i thought well like
we should you know look as the talmud
does turn away
uh turn away the attempted convert three
times i think is the rule
uh and then but that's led to a lot of
problems in jewish history as
as i'm sure you know and so first of all
i want to get why didn't people do that
today the attitude towards conversion
varied again historically with what the
prevailing culture around it
was like and and even by the way
although this may sound strange to some
of your listeners
even with whether converts were
suspected of being spies
or not for the government um because
in jewish history i mean children were
kidnapped and raised um in other
cultures
and and and were taken away to the army
um when they were young and came back
and knew nothing of that
i mean it's endless endless endless how
many yeah
how many ways that predominantly
christian but in some
ages muslim culture tried to eliminate
jewish culture
um it is a sad fact of history and i i
think
it's it's important to say that in terms
of uh
um interfaith relations in general we
think we live in what is a golden age to
the extent that we can't imagine what it
used to be like
no we're so spoiled yeah so yes although
unfortunately that doesn't mean that
anti-semitism has disappeared
no the reason that it went through the
mother was because i mean that
the simplest explanation is because you
always knew who the mother was
you didn't know who the father was know
if the father was jewish or not a child
is born you know the child is born of
the mother you don't know whether the
child is one of the father
um and so yeah that's
um and i think one other myth is you
know that that yeah so
it's obvious that you know i hear often
said
that oh it's not clear if jesus existed
let alone was a jew
and one of the things that's most
predominant about
the jews is how meticulous we are
about about writing and about kind of
record keeping
you know there's a reason i think you
know many jews going into accounting and
science even
and and part of that is that they were
meticulous so not only do we know that
jesus was a rabbi
i believe we know who his rabbi was
isn't that right right
yeah at least there are sources to that
yeah i mean it's so hard when you're
dealing with ancient i
happen to be in the middle of uh mary
beard's wonderful
history of ancient rome and and you know
she's she's a meticulous historian she
says rome's kept
again kept very meticulous records but
still there's so
much that one can't know for sure
um it seems to me pretty um
i won't say inarguable nothing is
inarguable but it seems pretty clear
that jesus
certainly existed it's hard to know
what teachings attributed to him he
actually taught and didn't teach
um and but my my own impression
and i certainly don't say this in any
way to uh offend my christian friends
um but my own impression is that jesus
himself was a religious jew
um and did not did not intend
to start a new tradition um but
obviously christianity sees it very
differently as they should
uh and and and then that's why there's
gonna be
christmas
yeah i mean but when we think about it i
mean we are
one faith uh the abrahamic faith and
there are different theological
um kind of tributaries that come off of
that and actually i want to go to uh
to abraham the patriarch of these three
great world religions
not the only religions but there are
three great worlds i love the fact that
jews have a word you know we jews make a
point two percent of the world's
population
and yet we have a name for the people
that aren't jewish we call them [ __ ]
which just means nations it doesn't
it's not like an insult it just means
but like can you imagine like people
that don't play in the nba there's like
a name for those
i know it's like when someone says i'm a
gentile what that means basically is i'm
not i'm
i'm part of the other yeah 99.2 what are
the odds
whatever yeah what are the odds what's
the world's population
i'm not you right uh
yes yeah so so speaking about abraham
as a man you know thinking about his
life and just how
how uh spectacular his life whether you
believe it literally
or figuratively that there was his
character there was this there's this
figure
who lived this extraordinary life and
recently i had on um
a man who's not jewish is the best of my
knowledge bill perkins
he's uh he's like a former hedge fund
trader he played football in college
he's a very interesting guy
and he wrote a book called die with zero
and it's all about basically estate
planning
and his thesis and you can watch this on
my uh on my youtube channel
his thesis is that if you if you die and
you
basically don't bounce a check to the
undertaker to the rabbi who's you know
giving the hespid
uh that you are a loser you know
basically alfred nobel was a loser
because for a variety of reasons you
should have used that money
when you were younger or given it to
your kids when they were younger not on
your deathbed
when you're 120 and they're 90. i could
not
possibly agree more in fact yeah i'm
going to get you this book then probably
i'm going to send you a copy of this
exactly those words in almost exactly
those words two or three days ago to a
friend of mine
which is i don't understand people who
die with a lot of money it's ridiculous
why would you do that yeah
why wouldn't you give it to you if
you're not going to give it to your
children
and hopefully you've taken care of that
if you have a lot of money that's right
use it for your joy and for charity
work better at the priorities charity
and your joy if you prefer
but but i honestly don't unders and i
think that there
is a psychological comfort
or a psychological reinforcement that
people get from seeing just the numbers
on the screen
um that are their accounts that add up
and and i understand that everybody has
their own kinds of issues
but but i want to say get over it yeah
just get over it i mean money
is can do so much in the world why would
you want it to sit
and just make more money right it's the
one way that it doesn't do something
right and it's it's the one way that you
can
his his thesis is convert money to
experiences and that experiences pay a
form of
compound interest which einstein as you
know called the greatest invention of
the human mind
compounding of interest because you know
it gets better and better every day and
gets better and better every year and
you always have it to look back on so
another corollary that i've added is you
know
you want to get married young you want
to have kids young you know
and you want to have as many kids as
possible at least in my case but but um
but the thing that i took away in the
comparison with abraham or avraham
abraham it was that he was not stingy
when he was when his wife sarah died he
went and bought the choices
of the of the fields he used the choices
silver
you know it's like we think now like
money's fungible i can use the color of
money who cares it's all the same
but he took the best of the money and
there was there was a distinction back
then
good money versus bad money and he um
and he bought this and then
uh for isaac he wanted his his son isaac
to
marry a wife and in those days what
would you get the uh the bride's family
as a bride price
you'd get them camels so he gave
thousands you know
millions of dollars worth of cap ten
camels a huge number of camels and
spices and bring
and then isaac married rebecca and then
later when he
when he does die or before he dies he
gets married again
and has many more kids yes and he sends
and it says very cryptically it says
he sent his kids eastward to the east
to the land of the east and i just think
it's like it's very interesting
some say those are the lost tribes in
india we know that there are jews in
india for thousands of years
um when you think about that are there
lessons you know for things like
estate planning and and other things
that we can learn from these stories and
and
specifically i want to talk about
parenting because i view the torah as
kind of like
you know i always say i'd rather have a
weather man or whether woman who's wrong
all the time than one that's right half
the time because at least you know what
to do not to do
and i want to know like are these
examples in the torah meant to teach us
counter
examples or are they meant to be like
role models we should be like omra
um the the uh
the frustrating answer is both um that
is there are things that
that the torah clearly intends to show
us by negative example
this is what you ought not to do right
um
lot for example offering his daughters
to the townspeople
there's no question that the torah
intends us to to think
this is not a good thing to do um but
the
fundamental my my own belief is that the
fundamental religious
orientation in the world is that of
gratitude and if you are grateful
you will be generous if you're not
generous then you're not really grateful
because you're grasping and holding and
you feel like you don't have enough
and you always must have more and that's
not the way clearly
avraham led his life or we should lead
our lives
the the assumption of religion is not
that nothing bad will ever happen
it's that whatever happens you can cope
with it
because you have this certainty and
strength and gratitude
there's in fact a phrase um that in in
i think it's chapter 24 that abraham was
blessed with everything
and he died happy yeah and when you
think about it had a very tough life in
a lot of ways he faced famine
bro you know he almost lost his child he
sends the other child out of uh his
father tried to kill him
right right so what does it mean that he
was blessed with everything
it means that he was blessed with
everything good and bad
light and dark and that's a life a life
is where but you have to approach it not
not as an optimist not with rose-colored
glasses
but with a sense of gratitude and
knowing that life will have
difficult times and and joyous times and
that
you can you will be okay in all times
because
you are who you are you're in an image
of god right
and being happy with what you have
that's the uh you know who is
who is wealthy he who is happy with his
lot yeah
exactly and and also the other
the other part of this about the
gratitude piece which i think that
people know
but they don't most of us don't know
well enough or don't think about it
often enough is
98 of what we have
was given to us i didn't
neither you and i nor the nobel prize
winners that you're going to talk to
they didn't earn their brains
had they been born with with a less good
brain
in a different society where it doesn't
matter how hard you work or how smart
you are
in a different age where it wouldn't
matter how hard you were how smart you
are
you know i live in a house i didn't
build with electricity
i didn't create with a computer that i
don't even know how it works much less
built in and on and on and on and on
look almost everything i have
was created for me by the efforts of
other human beings over the ages and
over time
so if you're not grateful you are blind
and i think to the many blessings that's
the core i mean as i understand it you
know hodea
is part of judaism and we get their name
from judah and that's what leia said you
know i was happy
and i rejoiced because i had gratitude
god has given me a child
that's right and so that is the essence
of being a jew and then the
countervailing aspect of it is that the
word israel
means to fight with god so my lately my
thing has been i say i don't know if i
believe in god
but i believe in religion and i believe
that there you know everybody has a
religion
it's clear to me even these nobel prize
winners and actually today you were
you're so dead on i was talking to ray
weiss he won the 2017
nobel prize he was born in 1932 in
germany
and he left germany in 1939 and we know
that that's when
uh german jewry it was basically its
course
die was cast and he was so lucky to come
to america
end up in a you know relatively
prosperous part of new york city he
wasn't rich
but then he made his way to mit and
there were all sorts of barriers against
quotas against jews back then
and and he succeeded and he won the
nobel prize at age 86
i mean i remember you know it's like i i
once read an interview with before he
died obviously
robbie who was the nobel prize yeah we
talked about him today
and they said tell me if you had stayed
back in the ghetto what would you have
become
and he said taylor
you know yeah that's the reality of it
you change
someone's circumstance and you change
the way that they can
uh so yeah yeah it's quite remarkable
it's very remarkable how much how much
is given to us and when i look at the
story so it's um every year at this on
the sabbath every every sabbath jews
read a different
uh section of the torah there's
basically 52 of them such that it works
out almost 52 of them so it works out
that there's one chapter per week
and that's the the torah reading that
you do in the synagogue when we used to
meet in synagogue before coven
and uh please let us get back to that
and and the point being uh
that every every week and including this
week and it's a fix to the lunar
calendar
so uh when this week occurs this week's
sabbath reading
involves uh joseph and it involves the
sale of joseph eventually
which leads to this incredible series of
events where the jews go
down to egypt eventually but the part
the the torah portions called the parsha
this chapter basically begins and it
says
you know um uh jacob you know was was
um you know had moved on after his wife
leia had died they had their second son
together he had 12 sons and a daughter
and um and he said he had he loved
joseph
joseph was his favorite and he made
joseph a coat of many colors the famous
technicolor dreamcoat
i think you know if i look up uh you
know how to create enmity between my
kids
i don't think there's a better way to do
it than to show favoritism too
and and he knew how you know the perils
of favoritism with his own father-son
relationship
and even with his grandfather who he
knew at least according to the story
why would the torah put in all these
flawed deeply failed
like figures as fathers and sons and
brothers there's not a good relationship
in the torah there's one romantic part
of the of
genesis and i say that's just about
genesis i think it's when
when um when jacob works for
14 years basically and the torah says
like it seemed like
uh went by in an instant because of his
love for rachel
that's like the closest tenderness that
you see in the whole play also
and rebecca have a moment and even
abraham at one point says i know how
difficult you are he says that to sarah
but you're you're certainly right that
romantic love
is not a core um of most of the stories
of genesis
also not a core of most of the story
[Music]
marriage was an economic institution at
least as much as it was a romantic
institution um and arranged marriages as
you know
um in most of the world were quite
common
and and worked reasonably well as such
marriages go
in terms of of sustaining people
although they did not have the option to
leave most of the time
and it also has a lot to do with the
status of women
which in such societies
was publicly very low and women had to
be protected by the institution of
marriage
um but uh
having said all of that what i would say
is
there are i mean one of the reasons why
judaism
is an exegetical tradition
and doesn't have a fundamentalist
orientation
is because the torah is the first word
of the tradition it's not the only word
um and even though it is the most
authoritative book
no rabbi ever says all you need to do to
know the answer to this deep question
just open the torah
it's always what the rabbis say about
the torah right right
um it's uh it's a different
it is different from the way especially
protestantism
sees the bible uh because
generally what you hear from rabbis is
that they're quoting as you quoted a
minute ago when you said who is wise one
who's
happy with what he has that's a rabbinic
statement from pirkei of oak
so
the things that the torah doesn't
mention explicitly are brought out
over the course of generations by
interpreters and by
mid-rushes by people who read into the
text
and romantic relationships are very much
a part of that
and when you look at the relationships
fraternal
relationships and yes it is true that
leia and rachel have a good set but then
they also have
a scene of great tension and vitriol
when you know there's
some sale of some fertilizers
could talk about this story a great deal
and and the stories that follow it i
actually
um just wrote about them but uh well i
should point out
rabbi before you go on that rabbi wolpi
has a wonderful podcast called off the
pulpit i listen every week religiously
after sabbath of course and uh and then
he also obviously sinai temple which is
a
co-sponsoring co-hosting this tonight
they have a wonderful youtube channel
please check out the youtube description
here
uh want to get as much coverage and
we'll talk maybe briefly about this book
why faith matters
and making lost matter we'll make to
mention that but please go on about what
you were writing about this week
well i was going to say i i mean this i
wrote about jacob and rachel and leia
and i started to write a weekly tarot
column for the jerusalem post and i was
writing about this
and and basically what i would
the way i would summarize not what i
wrote about but the
larger question you ask is
families are given to dysfunction
because human beings
compose families and human beings when
you say
why would a parent make the same mistake
that was made to them i mean freud wrote
about the repetition compulsion
but the truth is that torah had it
thousands of years before freud
that which was done and and and auden
says the same thing you know that
in his verse about that people generally
hurt because they were hurt
right we're victims of victims of i find
that
overly overly uh dramatic it's not
always true
it's not always true i mean that's part
of the part of the learning curve of
generations
is to undo what was done but sometimes
it takes a very long time it isn't done
right away
and in fact the very end of genesis
the unsung hero of james says
is someone named menasha who was
joseph's child and what happens is you
know every
for generations with isaac and yishma
with jacob and esau
the older child has
lost to the younger child the brothers
and joseph and what happens is jacob
blesses
menasha who's the older and ephraim
who's the younger and he crosses his
hands
so that he blesses the younger just like
has happened for every generation
with a greater blessing than the older
but menasha says nothing
for the first time at the end of the
book of genesis
brothers are finally reconciled they
each get their blessing but it's okay
and so it does in the end teach
but it takes time to get there and it
takes an effort just like it
does in life i mean i think about but i
didn't know 10 years ago
20 years ago or 30 years ago you know
yeah and so much so
that you bring that up about ephraim and
menasha that every friday night the
tradition is parents bless
their male children that they become
like a friend in menasha
and we bless our daughters to be like uh
leia and and
rebecca rachel the matriarchs and i i
think it is
important you know as much as we look
down on on sort of a
as a document or historical that the
matriarchs are portrayed in such a
better light than the patriarchs like
you don't see you see the matriarchs
making
really cunning decisions and brilliant
brilliant
stratagems uh throughout and you see
kind of the patriarchs kind of bumbling
worried that their wives will be
you know set upon by the kings of egypt
and and the women are just
very strong and very developed
characters
i do i as a as a
gross as a gross generalization about
life
in the many many years as a rabbi that i
have observed human beings
i think that you have to say that
emotional wisdom
is generally more prevalent among women
than among men
it just is now obviously there are a
billion different individual exceptions
yeah as a general rule women develop
faster
they i think are more acute more
sensitive to emotional registers
that's that's just how it is yeah that's
the only thing you know maybe i fault
the
reform community with is that they delay
the onset of the age of majority
for girls to the age of majority for
boys i've always felt that that was
regressive
in other words in orthodox judaism um or
and
and maybe even conservative too actually
don't know um
when do girls have their batman people
do it different yeah so
but in orthodox it's always when they're
12 girls are 12 and boys are 13
and reform it's always when both are 13
and i feel like that's punishing i
wouldn't want to punish my daughters if
they're more emotionally mature
as you say i mean it's it's just true
you see there's huge differences between
my daughters and my sons it's just you
know denying that denying the facts of
of life but i want to get into some
questions that we only have a few more
minutes some people are asking some good
questions i want to make sure that we
we ask them um so one question i always
wanted
uh to know is about um
uh well actually this has to do with
um yes the the what what is this notion
of dreams that occurs
in the torah in the book of genesis
particularly we see jacob having a dream
of ladder with angels going up
we see joseph having a dream and then he
has many dreams about the pharaoh about
the the cows and so forth why is
dreaming so in uh so endemic in the book
of genesis
so i would say two quick things one is
that dreams are
in the bible are considered messages um
it's clear that god is communicating in
one way or another both with jacob and
joseph they prove to be prophetic
dreams abraham also has dreams although
it's not his notice
and the other thing that about joseph
that's particularly beautiful
is joseph has dreams about himself and
his brothers
and they hate him for it that his
brothers bow down to him he ends up
doesn't matter how he ends up in prison
in egypt
there he interprets the dream of the
cupbearer and baker
and then the uh the cupbearer
when he is restored to his position
tells pharaoh joseph interprets the
dreams of pharaoh and becomes
viceroy to pharaoh in egypt so the
question
is joseph falls by dream and he rises by
dreams what's the difference
and the difference very beautifully uh
was said by a rabbi a generation ago
he said joseph falls when he can only
listen to his own dreams
he rises when he starts to listen to the
dreams of others as well
and so i think that that's also a
subtlety that the torah wants us to
understand
that you're not the only person who has
dreams everybody's always talking about
follow your dreams
listen to other people's dreams too you
know i mean you're
you're not only supposed to listen to
your own right and it's a saying we have
pilots have as well uh you know you
can't you have to learn from others
mistakes because you won't live long
enough to make them all yourself
a question from our listener boo rider
interesting name and he or she is asking
could uh could i ask
you a rabbi how do you interpret the
covid pandemic in a religious sense
maybe
is this meant to teach us something do
we do first of all i think this is
somebody who's ready to kill a
mockingbird
but second um the uh when i
i i really i'm a deep believer in
randomness
deep i think that god created the world
with randomness for
a very good reason for a very good
reason obviously um
but i don't interpret things like the
covet pandemic in
spiritual or religious terms except in
terms of our response
but when people say that god sent the
plague because people are bad or so on i
don't believe that for a second
um and there are lots and lots of
reasons why i don't believe it um
but here's why i would say that the
world is random in in part
um because if in fact good people
always had good things happen to them
and bad people always had bad things
happen
right then you would be good just so
that bad things won't if you're
irrational i have no moral content right
exactly it would be like you know it
would be the rational bet
so you there have to be unpredictable
things that we react to in moral ways
um and and i think the pandemic has
revealed
the reactions of various people in ways
that are better and worse and i'm going
to let you figure out
who is better and who is worse i'm not
going to go into that right now
yeah i mean it's interesting i've been
talking a lot uh to people
in in the kind of self-help uh sphere of
of life i'm talking to psychologists and
and so forth and
i i noted that like i made a joke that
you know if you search on google you can
search trends you can search
rabbi david wolpe and then you can see
over time how popular has that been
as a google search term a google trends
and of course it peaks you know when you
were
when you were born or it starts when you
were born and it keeps rising like a
hockey stick right
uh but then i googled like you know it
was the best thing that ever happened to
me
and then i said well what words you know
happen what words are most likely to
occur
before the words it was the best thing
that ever happened to me and it's pretty
much
like i got fired or i failed or i
lost the world city or whatever and that
was the best like we
get taught so much more viscerally and
it might
just be a symptom of the human condition
like no other animals are like that like
well we were starved to death and then
all of a sudden like we did we grew
another claw
you know like doesn't happen why do you
think that is unique to human
experience i don't know there's a
beautiful phrase um
from uh tom newton rabbi that the the
eye has a light part in the dark part
but you can only see through the dark
part there is something there is
absolutely something in
struggle and difficulty and failure that
teaches us more
than uh than ease and success yeah
that's certainly true i want to end with
the three questions that i ask all my
guests
um of course which is
um can you first provide for us a sixth
equation long theory of everything that
unifies quantum gravity
with the three stronger forces of the
nuclear and elections no i
i of course i can but i i i fear
i fear that if i take the thunder away
from your nobel prize winning guests
they'll they'll start transgressing on
my territory so
i fair enough yeah i thought you're
gonna said the margin isn't big enough
for me to include it
okay no my serious question uh that i do
ask all my
all my guests is uh what would you put
in your zava ah
and so for listeners that aren't
familiar in azava oz is concept of an
ethical will
first tracing back to a chapter in
genesis that's coming up when jacob
gathered
his 12 sons to offer them a blessing and
predict their future
and nowadays it's not only for jews
alfred nobel
left a material will but also an ethical
will that these
creations and inventions should make the
world better and that was part of the
requirement for winning the nobel prize
when i see you rabbi
what would you put in your ethical will
so that i would say the
two things that strike me immediately is
that the two most important
qualities of character that someone has
to have
are first of all to be kind i think that
kindness
is crucial to
human life and second to have stamina
that is the things that are worth doing
in this world
don't get done in an instant and you
will be discouraged and you will
fail and you have to keep at them
because if they really matter and
they're really worth doing
then you keep at them and of course if
it were my ethical will i would also say
to anybody who was my offspring
that there is wisdom and richness
in your tradition and in your people and
i hope that you are faithful to them
and that you pass that tradition on to
your children
yeah i would say that even to people
that aren't your biological
children but your ideological children
and that i think it's worth
investigating the faith of your birth i
i think
you know unless it was particularly
abusive obviously you can't speak in
every case but
but you know coming back to judaism
after learning so much about catholicism
and feeling such warmth
i spoke you know recently at a you know
catholic university not recently
earlier this year and um you know
learning a lot about it but it also
makes you deepen your appreciation for
your own tradition
and you know life is short and i think
that's that's a big lesson and so i
agree that
that you know at least taking it
seriously that's what i said earlier
i believe i embody this as a scientist
to wrestle with god to fight with god
the other name
for for jews israel means wrestle with
or fight with god
i believe i do that and it makes my uh
my
my sort of it strengthens the the
richness of my life
i would say okay second question rabbi
uh goes to a science you already asked
me two
oh no no well no i can ask you three
first one didn't count
the first one was zero no that one well
you kind of swung and missed but but
anyway we're gonna we're not gonna
that'll be for your third episode i'll
give you a couple of weeks to publish
that theory of everything
okay you've probably seen uh 2001 a
space odyssey
uh stanley cup but i remember it
somewhat
yeah well you might remember this iconic
scene where these primates discover this
this obelisk this monolith this thing
that's kind of uh
menacing and it's it's unclear what it
is but it later is found on the moon
or another one is found on the moon and
it's obviously meant to be discovered
when humanity is ready technologically
or otherwise to discover this i asked
this of
um of andrurian who is the widow
of of the late great carl sagan and i
said what would you put on a time
capsule
that would last a billion years like one
of these monoliths and she said
well i actually already did that i said
oh yeah and she had
made a recording of her brain waves uh
when she first fell in love with carl
sagan and nasa put that
on a plaque and launched it on the
voyager satellite and it's made of solid
gold
if anybody finds it you know please
return to me but it's made of solid gold
and it will last for a billion years
nasa engineers say
so it's a time count and she said i
asked her what would you put on it and
she said um
uh walked uh like act humbly
love mercy and act justly or something
like do justice to love mercy and to
walk humbly with your god although if
she said walk humbly with your god
she did not say that she left that off
so the quote from mika that's probably
as good as you could do
yeah so uh what would you put on your
monolith would you put anything
specifically it doesn't have to be a
religion or anything deep but
what what's sort of a very interesting
fact about the existence of of
earth if you will would you most like
some other civilization to know about
you know i was here we were here
um i think that
probably this is this is profoundly
unoriginal but probably in order for
them
i don't know if it would fit in a
monolith um but
in order for them to understand who we
are i would
either choose you know uh
a soliloquy from shakespeare uh a
section of the torah
or maybe a symphony of beethoven's in
other words something that is the
supreme
product of the of who we are and what we
can produce
and and let that uh let that speak for
itself knowing that whatever we put
will be misinterpreted and misunderstood
because it will be a million years from
now
yeah so that's why i inclined to music
as opposed to words
yeah they did put music they actually
recorded chuck berry i think
and uh and something else but you know
it's good they put it on that
not like a usb drive like here's an mp3
file that's not gonna be
too useful i mean if you wanna yeah if
you're not gonna put beethoven then at
least put sinatra
i actually had one of my guests uh he's
not a scientist he wrote a book about
artificial meat of all things
uh chase purdy and he said he put the
collective works of stephen sondheim
so you're in good company robert oh i
would absolutely i think
sondheim yes yes okay one of the supreme
one of the supreme problems all right
the last question also involves sir
arthur c
clarke and it goes the opposite
direction we've asked about your future
heirs ideologically and biologically
with your ethical will
we talked about a billion-year time
capsule into the future but now i want
to go backwards
so the name of this podcast is the into
the impossible podcast
and it's one of sir arthur's three
famous laws the first one being
the any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
to which michael shermer who i believe
you know well said something like any
sufficiently advanced
civilization is indistinguishable from
god
or aliens i forget exactly what
schermer's law is
um uh and then his second law of arthur
c clarke is any
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert i think you could say
rabbi
for any rabbi there's an equal officer
but his last statement was
uh the only way of discovering the
limits of what is possible
is to go beyond them into the impossible
and that's sort of our
our catchphrase here and i want to ask
you kind of in the uh
and a sense of advice to your former
self what would you tell a 20
year old david walpe before he was a
rabbi
what kind of advice something that
seemed mystifying stymieing
intimidating menacing perhaps that
because you had courage
and and you've overcome a lot in your
life we will you know i
haven't had much time to talk about the
things that you've personally overcome
but let's just say
what would you tell 20 year old version
of yourself to do to go into the
impossible for the benefit of
of the future version of you
um i think that i would say
the same thing that i say
to younger people that i've learned
which
is that
that your anxieties
about the future and your
lack of assurance about yourself
in the present will dissolve
so why not dissolve them now
that is if you can accelerate the
process
of having confidence in yourself
so that you don't have to do it in 10 or
20 or 30 years
you will be astonished at um
almost all of your almost all of your
regrets will be about things that you
didn't have
the assurance and the calm to do um
so do them do
um you will be uh
and and and the other thing that i would
say which is
which is the same message in a way but
different
is uh
when people tell you don't be afraid to
fail failing hurts
but the amazing thing about being hurt
is you don't
die of an emotion so
go into the pain of failure
and being hurt and discover how
actually powerful you are that you can
feel it and still go on
and and that i mean i think the
indispensable quality to lead a good
life is courage
interesting well rabbi you have a lot of
courage and i want to thank you for your
your generosity of time and spirit uh
where can people find you
online or or elsewhere uh facebook i'm
on twitter
um or just if you google rabbi wolfie
you'll
you'll find me and uh find how to get in
touch with me
and uh find books columns uh
all the time all the paraphernalia your
next book will be you know the twitter
torah because you are a master
you have a rapier sharp tweeting finger
and thumb
uh rabbi i want to thank you i'll give
you some applause now
uh here thank you so much i want to wish
you
a wonderful uh hanukkah and hogsomayock
fill up
full of light like you give to the world
and i want to wish you strength
uh and health and i hope that we'll talk
uh a talk in our next holiday episode
maybe purim
or tuba spot i'm going to get you for
all the holidays rabbi
until until you get sick of me thank you
so much
bye rabbi happy happy hanukkah and i'll
take us out
with a clip from our good friend miguel
tully
who runs yeti tears and he's written a
wonderful song which will take us out on
this hanukkah edition of the into the
impossible podcast
happy hanukkah everybody wherever you
may be
continue letting the light of good and
extinguish the darkness as they say only
light can distinguish the darkness
thank you have a wonderful evening
wherever you may be stay tuned for
another episode
coming up next week on the into the
impossible podcast where we'll be
getting you sick of nobel prize winning
intellects
good night for now bye bye thank you
rabbi